ADAM ROBERTS: OK.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Adam Roberts, and I
am a food blogger from the
website The Amateur Gourmet, and
I'm also the author of a
new cookbook that some of you
just purchased called Secrets
of the Best Chefs.
Thank you so much for having
me here at Google.
This has been really cool.
I got to eat at the big--
what was it called?
MALE SPEAKER: The big table.
ADAM ROBERTS: It
was very good.
I took pictures.
I'm going to blog
it on Monday.
So anyway, I'm going to tell you
all about myself and the
story of how I started
my food blog and how
it led to this book.
And actually, Google plays a
role that story, so this is
like interactive storytelling.
Anyway, so what happened was I
started my blog back in 2004.
I was in law school at Emory in
Atlanta, and I came from a
family where nobody cooked.
My mother didn't cook, my
father didn't cook, my
grandparents didn't cook.
And for some reason, going to
law school, I just got very
interested in cooking.
And so I would watch the Food
Network and I would sort of
write down recipes.
And then one day, I gave it a
try and I got behind the stove
and I made, I think, it was
Mario Batale's tomato sauce,
and I was hooked.
And I just started cooking
all the time, and it
was a lot of fun.
So around that time,
like in 2004--
which was my third year
of law school--
two of my friends suggested
that I start a food blog.
And back then, in 2004,
it wasn't like
an established thing.
I'm sure all of you guys
read food blogs.
Are you guys all big
food people?
Cooks and readers--
OK, yes, one person.
So anyway, it wasn't like an
established thing back then.
So I started my food blog in
January of 2004, and I called
it The Amateur Gourmet because I
was learning how to cook and
I didn't know anything and
I wasn't an authority.
And the goal of the blog when
I started it was really just
to share all my disasters and
things that went wrong and
things that went right
and what I was
learning as I went along.
So when I started my blog,
I had about five readers,
including my parents
and my roommate and
maybe two other people.
And this is where Google
enters the story.
Around the end of January 2004,
Janet Jackson, you might
recall, showed her breast
at the Super Bowl.
Do you guys remember that?
And I decided it would be funny
to make a Janet Jackson
breast cupcake.
So I made a cupcake and I had
mocha frosting and a Hershey
kiss as the nipple.
It had the nipple shield--
remember it had a shield
around her--?
Yeah, I did like white icing,
and I put that on my blog.
And I went to school
the next day.
And when I got home, my site
had had 70,000 hits.
And it was linked all over and
CNN actually called me and
asked if they could come over
and do a story on the Janet
Jackson breast cupcake.
And so Google enters the story
here, though, because that
post became so popular and went
so viral that when people
were googling cupcake, that
would come up as a top result.
And so I actually had a picture
of her breast at the
top of that post, and I
got flagged for having
inappropriate conduct and I
actually got kicked off of
Google after that.
So I had to the take off-- it
was a whole elaborate thing.
Anyway, I got back on
and so that's my
Google related story.
I hope you like that part
of [INAUDIBLE].
So anyway, after that I actually
grew an audience.
I had a lot of readers of my
blog, and I sort of had to
make a choice of I wanted to
keep doing zany sort of
cupcakey pop culture things, or
if I really wanted to take
cooking seriously and really
start to become more of a
serious home cook, and that's
sort of what happened.
So in 2005, I actually
sold my first book.
It was a book of essays called
The Amateur Gourmet, and it
was about learning how to
cook from point zero.
It was basically my story of
knowing absolutely nothing
about food and cooking and
getting to a point where I
could make dinner for a group
of-- at the end the book, I
would make a giant five first
course tasting menu dinner for
10 friends.
So that first book was about
learning how to cook.
And actually that book led--
the Food Network, it caught
the attention of the
Food Network.
And they hired me to host a web
show for a year called The
FN Dish, which was sort
of their, like, Food
Network, F dot N dot.
Then it was, like,
effing dish.
What was funny was they really
wanted to create these viral
web videos that would set the
world on fire, but it was hard
because they didn't want to make
fun of any of the Food
Network people and it
had to be very PC.
So actually it was funny.
I got to interview Rachael
Ray for that.
And when I sat down to interview
her, the director
said, don't ask her
any questions yet.
We're going to start rolling
tape and we'll
tell you when to start.
So she sat down and I sat down
and I said hi, I'm Adam, and
she said hi.
We just sat there in stony
silence for 23 seconds.
And I was fidgeting and really
nervous and she was just sort
of sitting there.
And then they said OK go,
you can ask questions.
And I started the interview
and she perked
up and it was great.
But when it was over, I said to
my director if you want a
viral video, you have to put
those 23 awkward seconds with
Rachael Ray on the Web.
And actually, if you Google
that, you'll see there is a
video called 23 Awkward Seconds
with Rachael Ray.
And that's basically my crowning
achievement in my
year at the Food Network.
And not shockingly, they didn't
really keep me on very
long after that.
So I had a year at
the Food Network.
The other sort of controversial
thing that I did
there was Anthony Bourdain is a
famous Food Network critic.
He really doesn't like
the Food Network.
So when I was at the South Beach
Food and Wine Festival,
we stumbled upon him and he was
in a kitchen somewhere.
And we said to him, you can do
an interview with me and rant
about the Food Network.
You can say whatever you want
and we'll put it on the Food
Network website, because again,
the goal was to create
these viral videos.
And so he did.
You can find that if you want.
He just rails against
the Food Network.
And actually, they put in
on the home page of
foodnetwork.com.
And apparently, a lot of the
Food Network stars called up
the president of the Food
Network and were like, why do
you have this video of Anthony
Bourdain trashing the Food
Network on the Food
Network home page?
And they said well, we're
trying to go viral.
So again, I lost that
job after a year--
not shocking.
But I'm telling you all this and
giving you my trajectory
because that all led to this
book that is for sale in the
back at a very reasonable $10.
It's called Secrets
of the Best Chefs.
So essentially around the time
that I finished the Food
Network show, I realized
that I wanted to
go to the next level.
I wanted to--
if I was an amateur home cook
and if I was self-taught, I
wanted to now sort of go
forward a little bit.
And so the idea came to what
would it be like to travel the
country and cook with 50 world
class chefs and home cooks and
to really to cook with them side
by side and to absorb as
much as I could in
the process?
And a lot of chef
cookbooks don't
really adapt their recipes.
Chefs don't really have the
mindset of home cooks.
They're thinking about
how to feed large
quantities of people.
They're thinking of how to
dazzle you with inventiveness
and things that don't
really apply when
you're cooking at home.
So I felt like I was in a really
good position to be an
advocate for the home cook while
cooking in the kitchens
of great chefs, and
that's sort of how
this book came about.
So in 2010, I sold the book
to Artisan Books.
And they do the French Laundry
cookbook, they do all of
Thomas Keller's cookbooks,
so they're a really great
publisher, and so I felt really
excited that I was
going to get to do this
hardcover 400 page multicolor
pictures, because in the last
book-- the first book that I
wrote was just a book of essays,
so I was ready to go
on to the next thing.
So the concept, again, was that
I was going to travel the
country, cook with 50 chefs and
home cooks, and then each
of them were going to teach
me three dishes.
And I was going to go
home and adapt the
dishes for home cooks.
And that's pretty much
how it worked.
So I started in New York.
Melissa Clark is a recipe writer
for the New York Times
and she's a cookbook author.
And so I started with her and I
said to her, I want to learn
how do you come up with original
recipes that you can
published in the New York
Times on a weekly basis?
Like, how do you even think
of like these recipes?
And so she took me the Union
Square farmers' market in the
middle of Union Square,
New York.
And we went food shopping,
and she just
started grabbing radishes--
beautiful radishes--
and she put them in a bag, and
then she got sugar snap peas
and filled the bag.
And she saw sheep's milk ricotta
and bought that and
she saw this beautiful loaf of
bread and she bought that.
And so she started buying
all these ingredients.
And we went back to her
house in Brooklyn.
She just started-- it was like
the Tasmanian devil.
She just started-- she took the
bread and she sliced and
she put it in a toaster.
Then she took the sheep's milk
ricotta and put it in a bowl
and stirred it around and then
she sliced the radishes and
she sliced the sugar
snap peas.
And she stirred the sugar snap
peas and radishes in a bowl
with olive oil and lemon juice
and garlic and anchovies.
And when the toast came out of
the toaster, she put the
ricotta on top and then she put
that whole mixture of the
sugar snap peas and radishes
on top and she
said, that's crustini.
That's the first recipe.
And I said wait, how
did you did that?
I don't know, she goes.
That's how I do it.
So it's just sort of watching
that process.
And what I learned from her is
that it's all about momentum.
It was just her energy
of just grabbing
things and trying things.
She said, if you fail at
it, just call it recipe
developing, which is great.
And she also said that if you
don't like the way something
comes out, just rename
the dish.
And she actually wrote about
this recently in
the New York Times.
She says she wants to make this
eggplant salad that was
supposed to be like the
traditional eggplant salad,
but the eggplant was
really bitter.
So she just named the dish
bitter eggplant salad, and
there it was.
So I started with her, and I
kind of think of this book as
sort of a mural or something
where I started in this part
and I sort of grew outwards
and outwards and
outwards and outwards.
So I thought, OK, I have her.
Who do I want to
cook with next?
And actually, Rebecca Charles
is the chef of the Pearl
Oyster Bar in New York, which
is a really well known
restaurant there.
And from her, I learned how to
cook [FRENCH], which is to
cook in the moment, to actually
cook hot restaurant
dishes on order.
She taught me how to take two
pans and a pair of tongs and
to make a beautiful place of
restaurant quality food.
So she got these two pans, she
put them on the stone, she
turned on the heat.
In the first pan, she added a
splash of oil and the second
pan she added butter.
And in the first pan,
she took fish--
I think it was trout,
or no, it was cod.
She put cod in the first pan
and started searing it.
In the second pan, she put sugar
snap peas and corn and
heirloom tomatoes
with the butter.
So she had these two pans going
and she used the tongs
to stir around the vegetables
and she used the tongs to flip
over the fish.
And all of this is
going on at once.
And by the time she was done,
she poured the vegetables onto
a plate, she lifted the
fish on top, and it
was the most gorgeous--
you can see it in the book.
I mean, it's the most beautiful
plate of restaurant
food and she used were two
pans and a pair of tongs.
That lesson of just sort of
seeing how with the most
simple equipment you can make
really gorgeous restaurant
quality food was really
instructive to me, that it's
not so much about what fancy
equipment you have at home.
It's really just about the
rhythm of it and really
understanding how to interact
with food as you make it.
And so that's how the book
started to grow.
And I went to 11 different
cities.
I went to Chicago, San
Francisco, LA, Portland,
Seattle, New York, DC, Athens,
Georgia, Atlanta, Georgia.
And so I was really trying to
create a portrait of American
cooking and to try to get as
many different cuisines and
cultures and chefs, both high
and low, and older chefs and
younger chefs.
We have a 24 year old
chef who was on Top
Chef, and we have a--
sorry, I knocked that
microphone-- like 60 something
year old chef.
I really wanted to get
a panorama of chefs.
And the hardest part of writing
the book was not the
cooking and it wasn't the
adaptation of the recipes,
which I'll talk about
in a second--
it was just booking chefs.
Chefs are difficult--
to nail them down, to convince
them to do this book.
I mean, because really what I
was asking was for access to
their kitchens.
I was saying, let me into your
kitchen and then show me what
you do here and there's going
to a photographer.
And a lot of chefs are like, no
way, we're not going to let
you do that.
But this chefs did let
me in, actually--
I think what the reason that
they let me in was that I feel
like the more confident you
are as a chef, the less
threatened you are by somebody
stealing your ideas because
it's not so much about the
ideas, it's more about the
philosophy of how you
approach food.
So as you read through this
book, you'll see that each
chef has a different attitude
about food and it sort of
reflects their own personalities
and their own
personas through their food, and
it has very little to do
with a secret formula
or a guarded recipe.
It has much more to do with--
Daniel Patterson, the chef at
Qua here in San Francisco is a
great example of that, because
he's all about the very best
ingredients.
He goes foraging for ingredients
everywhere.
And so for him it's not about
the secret formula of a recipe
that he has to keep guarded to
himself, it's more about
getting these gorgeous radishes
delivered to him by a
farmer and then going foraging
for strange herbs and weeds
that he then puts
into the salad.
It's not something that somebody
can steal, it's more
just a way of teaching.
So that was sort of how the
book came together.
Actually at the front of the
book, in the front matter--
this is the book again--
I have the 10 lessons that I
learned from cooking with 50
of the country's best chefs.
And so I thought I would go
through those and talk about
them a little bit.
So these are the 10 essential
rules for cooking like a chef.
And the first one is actually
probably the most cliche.
You've heard it before, but I
kind of want to articulate my
own slant on it, which is
to taste as you go.
Now tasting as you go,
you hear that a lot.
You'll watch the Food Network
and they'll say taste as you
go, taste as you go.
Well, for me what that ended up
being about was about not
just tasting for salt and not
just tasting for whatever else
you're tasting for.
What you're really trying to
do as a great chef and what
these great chefs did is in
their mind they had a vision
of what this dish should taste
like and then they were
getting it to taste that way,
which is something that a lot
of home cooks don't
think about it.
Most home cooks, I
think, are pretty
strict recipe followers.
Most of my friends who cook for
me or have people over for
dinner they follow a recipe
like it's the Bible.
It's like if it says a quarter
teaspoon of paprika and they
only have an eighth of a
teaspoon, they'll throw
everything out and start--
I used to do that
when I started.
If I didn't have exactly what
I needed to make a recipe, I
wouldn't do it.
And chefs never do that.
Chefs just adapt.
They engage with their food.
And the real key is
understanding the tools
available to you to make
your food taste great.
And so for me-- and you'll see
this in the first lesson about
taste as you go--
those tools are fat, and when
I say fat I mean olive oil,
cream, butter.
If you want to enrich a dish,
every chef-- and this won't
come as a shock to you--
was generous with fat.
I mean, they would take butter
and pop it into a pan, or they
would take cream and
pour it all.
And you don't have to do that
at home because you're not
trying to kill your family, but
just to understand that
that's a tool available to
you, that that's a way to
enrich your food to make it
taste a little better.
But if you're making eggs and
they're not coming out as
creamy as you want them and you
add a little more butter
at the end or you add
some cream to the--
it's a tool that you can use
to make food taste better.
And then the second tool,
of course, being salt.
Taste as you go is generally
about salt,
salting your food properly.
But what's really interesting
about chefs if they taste for
salt at every stage
of cooking.
They're not just tasting it at
the end and adding salt to
make sure it tastes good.
Michel Richard is a famous
French chef that's in this
book, and he was making
a mixture that had
raw chicken in it.
That's like the worst thing you
could do in the world is
to eat raw chicken, but it sort
of showed his mettle as a
chef that he just sort ate a
spoonful of ground up raw
chicken to see if it was
salty enough, and
he added more salt.
But that's what chefs do-- they
taste it at every stage.
And the final thing that a lot
of home cooks don't know about
in terms of tasting as you go
is acid, how to use acid to
make your food taste better.
And when I say acid, I mean
vinegar, I mean lemon juice,
any kind of citrus,
lime juice.
Chefs use acidic elements all
the time, and it's such a
remarkable thing how
much better it'll
make your food taste.
If you make something as simple
as a chicken breast and
you roast it in the oven and
you take it out and you
squeeze a lemon over it, I think
that will enhance it
immeasurably, because it perks
up-- it makes the taste pop in
your mouth.
And chefs use acid all the
time-- they use balsamic
vinegar, they use cider vinegar,
they use lemon juice,
all that kind of stuff.
So I think tasting as you go is
so essential, that that's
why I talked so long
about it just now.
The second essential rule that
I learned cooking with the
chefs was to put ingredients
on display.
That sounds like
a strange one.
But so many of these homes--
I got to cook with Alice
Waters in Berkeley.
And when I went into her home,
she had these basketballs of
beautiful ingredients, like
just really unusual
ingredients that she'd gotten
from the farmer's market like
watermelon radishes and things
I'd never even seen before.
There are so many chefs that I
cooked with who literally had
the exact same thing.
Their kitchens were full of
beautiful ingredients that
they put on display.
In fact, actually, one of the
chefs that I cooked with,
Anthony Martin, who's the chef
at TRU in Chicago, had worked
for Joel Robuchan, who's a
legendary French chef.
And he said Joel Robuchan's
kitchens always had
ingredients displayed in the
kitchen to inspire cooks.
And so when I was in the middle
of writing this book, I
bought a basket--
I just went to a store and
I bought a basket.
And I put it on my counter and I
made myself go at least once
a week to a farmer's market.
I made myself buy things that I
had no idea what I was going
to do with them and I would
bring them home and I just put
them in the basket.
And it was amazing, because
having it on display and just
seeing it there was a trigger to
get me to use it and to get
me to cook more often, because
I would come home after
working all day.
And usually what happens--
I don't if you guys relate-- is
you get home from work and
the last thing you want to
do is go food shopping.
It's like you don't want to then
get back into your car
and drive to the store
go food shopping.
So if you have your ingredients
displayed out
there and you just have
beautiful things and you have
a box of pasta and let's say
you have broccoli rabe out
there, or whatever you buy, and
then you make your pasta
with a fresh ingredient, you're
much more likely to
cook if you have ingredients
on display.
And also it's just sort of
the color and the actual
liveliness of it, just sort of
seeing this beautiful food in
your kitchen just creates an
environment in your kitchen
that makes you want
to cook in there.
I think these little
psychological triggers that
you don't think a lot about
that actually don't seem
important--
it probably seems like the least
important thing in the
world to put ingredients on
display-- actually can be the
difference between ordering
Chinese food
and actually cooking.
So to me, that was actually
an important one.
The third one is sort
of tied up in that.
If it looks good before you cook
it, it will taste good
after you cook it.
So many times with the chefs
in this book, they would be
prepping something that was
not-- it should not have
looked appetizing at that stage,
but it still looked
beautiful and made me
want to eat it.
Like Charles Phan, the chef at
The Slanted Door here in San
Francisco--
I cooked with him.
And he taught me how make this
steamed chicken dish where it
was a clay bowl and he put raw
chicken that he cut up into it
and he put slivered ginger and
garlic and fermented black
beans and scallions.
And it was raw chicken with all
those things and he was
about to place it a steamer.
But just looking at it, the
raw chicken with all that
stuff, I just knew it was going
to taste good, because
something about the visual of
how that looked-- and I think
that that's really important for
home cooks to understand.
If you're making something and
it's just not doing it for
you-- like, if you're making a
dish that sort of looks gray
or brown and all you need to do
is add green herbs or red
chilies to make the color pop,
that actually will make it
taste better too.
I think the visual ties in
to how things taste.
So if it looks good before you
cook it, it will taste good
after you cook it.
And it was really true
throughout the book.
And number four is an
interesting one.
It's use your internal timer.
So it was funny, I cooked
with Gary Danko--
I keep referencing all these
San Francisco chefs.
So Gary Danko-- it was funny,
he taught me how to make a
blueberry crostata.
And he made the dough, he rolled
it out, he put the
blueberry filling, he folded it
up, and then he put it in
the oven, and he walked away
to do something else.
And I said, wait, aren't you
going to set a timer?
And he looked at me like I was
totally crazy-- like, a timer?
And chefs never set timers.
I never once in writing this
book with over 150 recipes and
50 chefs did I ever see
a chef set the timer.
And I started to ask myself,
well, why is that?
And I think it ties into what
I was saying earlier about
home cooks being slaves to
recipes, that where you feel
you have to cook it for exactly
50 minutes or bake the
lasagna for 47 minutes
and 32 seconds.
That's not how cooking works.
And cooks are engaged with
what's happening in the
kitchen at every stage, and
that includes how long
something is going
to cook for.
So with the crostata, what
he was looking for--
it's actually not even
just looking, it's
listening and smelling.
So he smelled it when
it was ready.
And he looked at it,
and it was golden
brown on the outside.
But what he was looking for--
he was just looking for a
visual clue as a very
simple thing--
he was looking to see if
blueberries in the middle of
the crostata were at a boil,
if the liquid was boiling,
because there was corn starch
as a thickener in the
blueberries.
And the corn starch doesn't
dissolve until
it reaches a boil.
So that's all he was looking for
was for the liquid to be
boiling at the center, and then
he took it out the oven,
and it was delicious.
But I think what's important
about using an internal timer
is to be engaged with food in
your kitchen as you're making
it, that idea of engagement.
So I think people, when they
follow recipes are sort of
disengaged.
It's like, I'm going to follow
this rule, I'm going to follow
this rule, and that will yield
this result, sort of a
mathematical way of cooking.
And chefs are not like that.
Chefs are totally, absolutely
100% immersed in their kitchen
and totally aware of everything
that's happening
all at once and reacting to
it as it's happening.
And similar to that is
number five which is
to control the heat.
A lot of chefs--
or a lot of recipes will say to
you, put it on high heat,
walk away, and come back in 30
minutes, or put it at a simmer
and walk away and come back.
And again, chefs would
never do that.
Chefs are always noodling with
the dial on the stove so that
if something is boiling too
rapidly, they lower the heat.
If something is at too
low of a simmer,
they'll raise the heat.
But it's, again, being really
engaged with food as it's
happening and coming back and
lowering and raising it-- and
so, that whole experience of
being engaged with your food.
The heat is kind of funny, too,
though, and this is sort
of tangential thing, which is
that a lot of people ask me
what did I learn overall?
How has my cooking
changed at home?
And the biggest thing I say is
actually the boldness, that
I'm much bolder when it
comes to cooking now.
And the story I like to tell
is Susan Feniger, who's the
chef from Street in Los Angeles
and who's also on Top
Chef Masters.
You might know her.
She had a show on the Food
Network called Two Hot
Tamales, which was on
a long time ago.
But when I cooked with her,
she got a pan, she
put it on the heat--
she put on high heat--
and then she started talking
to me, and we were just
talking and talking and talking
and talking, chatting
and chatting.
The pan was getting hotter and
hotter and hotter and hotter
and hotter, and at some point,
she's like, well, this is how
I make my black peppered
clams.
And she just added all these
clams to this pan that had oil
and it just burst into flames.
It was like Mount Vesuvius
erupted in flames and she did
not flinch at all.
It as if room had just exploded,
but she was like,
mhmm, mhmm.
I was like, whoa.
And so actually the way that I
wrote this book that all the
chefs that when I cooked them,
I took frantic notes.
I was writing things down
at every second.
I was writing, writing,
writing.
What I didn't want to do is I
didn't want the chefs to give
a recipe and then to photocopy
that recipe into the book,
because I thought that would
be totally useless
for the home cook.
I wanted to write it
down, what I saw--
I wanted to write down what I
saw happening in the kitchen,
and then I wanted to
replicate that.
So my method was to take
notes, write out my own
recipe, go home, cook it based
on what I saw and what I
wrote, and then if it didn't
come out right, to email the
chef and say hey,
when I made it I
didn't come out correctly.
So with that recipe, which was
a black pepper clam recipe,
when I was testing it at home,
I invited my friend Rob over,
and I was like, I'm going to
make this dish tonight that
Susan Feniger taught me.
When she made it, she got the
pan really hot and there was
this big flame ball, but I'm
not going to do that.
I'm a little scared, so I'm just
going to get it pretty
hot and it will be hot enough,
but it's not going to
be flame ball hot.
It will just be moderately
hot.
He's like, OK, whatever.
And so I started
heating my pan.
20 seconds went by, and I'm
like it has to get hotter.
And a minute went
by, I was like--
I just sort of started playing
with, do I want to do it now?
I was holding the clams
and I had the oil.
I was like, am I going to do
it, am I going to do it?
And at some point, I was like,
OK, here we go, and
I threw them in.
And I had the exact
same thing.
It was a flame ball.
And the difference was when
she did it, it was, again,
like nothing happened.
When I did it, I was shaking.
I poured into a bowl and
I was giving it to Rob.
I was like, here you go.
He's like, what's wrong?
I was like, nothing.
But just that experience
of how chefs are bold,
they're just bold.
It's like that whole thing of
having scars on your arms and
knife cuts and burns, it's
like they're just bold.
And so I tie that into that
thing of controlling the heat,
which is that they get
their pans hot.
They're not scared to get their
pans hot, they're not
scared of fire, they're
not scared of death.
You just have to just be
bold, be a bold cook.
And they're bold at everything
else, too, I should say, too.
Like salt--
there's another story.
I keep going on tangents,
but why not?
One of the chefs in the book was
Harold Dieterle, who won
season one of Top Chef, if you
guys watched Top Chef.
He taught me how to make his
creamed corn, which is one of
his famous dishes at Perilla
in New York.
And so all it is is fresh corn
that cook with cream, you
blend up half of it, and then
you stir it in with more fresh
corn, and that's his
creamed corn.
And at the end he said, OK,
Adam, why don't you season it?
So I took the salt shaker and
I put it on the little
sprinkle holes and I sprinkled
some salt and I stirred it
around and I tasted it.
And he's like, what
do you think?
I was like, I think it's good.
Why don't you taste it?
So then he took a spoon and
he tasted and said, mhmm.
And he took the dial and turned
it to the hole at the
top, he turned the salt thing
upside down, and a stream of
salt went pouring in.
He turned it back up and turned
it around and was like,
now taste it.
I was like, whoa.
It was like the difference
between a
candle and a firework.
It was explosively flavorful.
And chefs just add tons of salt,
they add tons of butter,
they get their pans
really hot.
They're bold, chefs are bold.
OK, enough tangents.
Number six is use your ears,
which is tied into the whole
being engaged in the kitchen,
to engage with
food as you make it.
And so one of the chefs, who I
actually just did a dinner
with here in San Francisco
at Tartine after hours.
Her name is Samin Nosrat
and she's amazing.
She's sort of a home cook.
She's done some things in
restaurants in San Francisco.
Anyway, she taught me how to
make her buttermilk marinated
chicken, where you take a whole
chicken, you marinate it
in buttermilk, and then
you roast it.
So we were in the other room
while the chicken was being
roasted, and she heard
a loud sizzle.
And she said, the chicken's
talking to me.
I have to go, I'll
be right back.
And she went into the kitchen
and she lowered the
temperature in the oven.
And I said, so you just heard
that and you knew?
She goes, yeah, it sizzled
so I knew it's too hot.
I had to lower the
temperature.
And again, that sort of tied
into not using a timer, being
engaged, reacting to food
as it's cooking.
That's what chefs do.
Number seven is a pretty good
rule, which is just don't use
pepper the way that
you use salt.
Salt and pepper are
not always--
they don't always go together.
And in fact, 95% of the time
chefs did not use pepper when
they seasoned something.
They season it with salt,
and they use all
different kinds of salt.
They use sea salt, they use
kosher salt, they use
Himalayan rock salt, they use
all different kinds of salt.
But pepper is only used when
they want to add that very
specific peppery flavor
to something.
And I think a lot of people
think that they're just going
to add salt, add pepper, add
salt, add pepper, and that's
not how chefs do it.
Chefs add pepper only if
they want that flavor.
So that's something
to think about.
Number eight I think
you guys like,
which is use the internet.
A lot of chefs are actually
very humble about the fact
that they don't know everything
and they want to
learn things, and that if they
don't know something, they're
not afraid to go on the internet
and look it up.
So Naomi Pomeroy, who's the
chef at Beast in Portland,
which is an amazing restaurant,
she told me she
uses the internet all the time
to learn new techniques and to
learn things.
And I think that that's
important, because I think a
lot of people at home feel like
they have to either be an
authority when they make food,
they have to know everything.
And it's like to open yourself
up and to be open to learning
and bringing new things
into it what you
do already is important.
I think a lot of chefs
were open to that.
Number nine--
I think this is the most
important rule, because I
think this is the difference
between actually cooking and
not cooking, which is
clean with fluidity.
So when I started my blog and I
started cooking, I would do
would probably a lot of you do,
which is I would cook a
dish or I'd make dinner, I would
pile dishes in the sink,
I would go watch TV, go watch
something on Netflix, go to
sleep, check my email the
next day, do my work.
And those dishes would sit, and
they would kind of crust
over and a whole family of
bacteria would grow in it.
Chefs never do that.
Chefs are always cleaning
while they're cooking.
It's a fluid process.
So what they would do, as I've
said, they're sauteing
something in a pan, they would
pour whatever's in the pan
into a bowl, they take that pan,
they put it in the sink,
they run water.
They stir around the bowl, they
put that into another
pan, they take that bowl,
they put it in the
sink, they run water.
They put it in the oven, they
clean those two bowls.
They wipe down the counter.
The thing comes out of the oven,
they pop it onto a cake
stand, they clean that thing.
And so they're are always
cleaning while they're
cooking, which makes tons of
sense, because when you're
done you have a beautiful plated
dish and you have a
clean kitchen.
It's wonderful and it
makes you cook more.
Because when I have dinner
parties now, I do that.
If I have a dinner party,
I'll make the dessert--
so I'll make a cake and then
I'll clean all the baking
stuff that I used to
make the cake.
Then I'll make the next dish
and so when I'm done, when
people come over to eat
dinner, the kitchen is
spotless, the food is prepared,
and all I have to
clean the dishes, the plates,
that people ate off of.
And it makes a huge difference
for people.
I think a lot of people don't
like to do dishes.
And if you clean fluidity, if
you clean while you go, you'll
cook a lot more.
Finally, number 10 is remember
everyone makes mistakes.
There's a funny little anecdote
from the book, which
is Elizabeth Faulkner, who was
the pastry chef here at
Citizen Cake in Orson,
although now
she's moved to Brooklyn.
I don't if you guys know that.
I think Citizen Cake closed.
Do you guys know if it closed?
That's so sad.
Anyway, so I was cooking
with her.
And she was teaching me how to
candy bacon for a salad.
So she had the pan on the stove,
she had the bacon, she
had maple syrup in it, she was
candying it, and her back was
to the stove.
She was talking to me and I was
asking about her life and
why she got interested
in cooking.
And as we were talking, the pan
burst into flames while
she was in the middle of an
emotional story, and I was
like, mhmm, and was watching.
I was like, I'm sorry, is that
pan supposed to be on fire?
And she's like, oh!
And so she grabbed the
pan-- and this is
the important part--
she put the flames out, she put
it in the sink, she ran
some water, got another pan, put
it on the stove, put some
bacon in it, put some maple
syrup in it, turn on the heat.
And before I could even blink,
the other pan was clean, the
bacon was candied,
and that was it.
She'd just recovered so quickly
from that mistake that
it was as if it never
happened.
And I think for home cooks--
when a mistake happens for me,
if I make a mistake in the
kitchen, it's like I need
weeks of therapy afterwards
to want to cook again.
And I think that seeing how
chefs recover when they screw
up was actually really
important, because you realize
that it's not about the mistake,
it's about the
recovery, it's about picking
yourself up and moving on and
just getting back on your feet
and getting going again.
So that's the tenth of my 10
essential rules for learning
how to cook.
And so I think at this point
if you guys have questions
about this book I'd love to
answer them, or I can keep
talking more if you'd like.
There's a microphone there,
so don't be shy.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So as everyone
here knows, we have a lot of
health problems in America and a
lot of people attribute that
to the lost art of
home cooking.
So you had this great experience
when you were in
school where you cooked for
the first time and had a
breakthrough moment and
became a serial cook.
How can we get other people to
have that experience and
really learn to love home
cooking and get that initial
experience and then
holding onto it?
ADAM ROBERTS: That's a
really good question.
Thanks for that.
I think the key is not to think
of cooking as a chore
and to think of cooking
as a treat.
And I think the way that you do
that is you don't make it
punishing to start.
So if you want to make the most
decadent chocolate cake
in the world or you want to make
doughnuts at home or you
want to make something really
bad for you but you want to do
it from scratch, I think it's a
great way to start, because
people don't want to learn how
to cook and learn how to make
some healthy dietetic dish
that's just sort of sad and
depressing.
I actually think that the more
you start by just being
indulgent and decadent at the
beginning as a cook and just
making the food that sounds so
delicious you can't even
imagine something tasting
better, so that's it's a
treat, so that it's something
you really
look forward to you.
Then you can kind of cut back
and scale back and start
making food that's more
realistic and healthy.
And I think the mistake so many
people make when they
start cooking at home is that
they punish themselves.
They make food that they don't
get excited about.
I think you have to get excited
about the dish that
you're making.
That's, to me, the key.
And the other thing, of
course, is just--
I actually think it's
psychological.
I think some people just aren't
into the idea of cooking.
It's like you can't really make
somebody a cook if they
don't really have
that interest.
My mom doesn't have that
interest at all.
I've been doing this for years
and it's not like she's
reading my blog-- which she
does-- and is inspired
to cook with it.
She's never going to
want to do it.
So unfortunately, I think
some people just
don't have that interest.
But I do think for those that
do have the interest to just
kind of be--
just treat yourself
the beginning,
and then scale back.
I think that's a good
way to get started.
MALE SPEAKER: Hello.
So you said the hardest part
of writing the book was
convincing all the 50 chefs
to work with you on this.
How did you actually do that
and were there times when
people said no, absolutely not
and you were able to convince
them to do it?
ADAM ROBERTS: A lot of
it was psychological.
Really, to be very honest, it
was like getting names, like
recognizable names, in the book,
and then calling up a
chef and saying, hey, I have so
and so and so and so who's
done it, why don't you do it?
It was a little bit like that.
It was funny.
I'm not going to name names, but
there was a city I went to
for the book where there are
two very famous chefs.
And I called the first chef--
when I say called the chef, it's
never the chef, it's the
PR team, it's the people
handling the chef.
And I said the PR team for
this famous chef, hi, I'm
coming to your city, I'd love
to cook with your chef.
And they were like, sorry,
he's very busy.
No, this is not a project
he'll want to do.
So then I called the other chef
and I was like, I'd like
to cook with you.
I'm coming to your city.
And they said, yeah, we'd
love to do it, so great.
So then I called back the first
team, the first chef,
and I was like, well, I just
want to let you guys know that
I'm cooking with this other chef
and this other chef is
sort of going to represent your
city and I just want to
make sure that's OK, because
your chef is really not to be
in the book and it's going to
look like this other chef is
the star chef of this city.
And they're like, oh, actually,
he does have some
time in the morning.
It was all the little games.
Also on that front, there were
chefs who I scheduled to cook
with who at the very last second
would cancel and it
would really throw us
into a turmoil.
I had a photographer that
took all the snapshot
pictures in the book.
So she would take a day
off work, and I
would buy the travel.
It was one chef I'm
thinking about.
We bought train tickets, we were
all ready to go, and then
they just called and canceled.
So there's a lot of that.
It was a lot of dealing with
chefs who changed their mind
of the last minute.
What was great about the book,
though-- the reason I'm so
proud of it and the reason I
actually think it's a great
book is that all of the chefs
who ended up doing it really
were engaged with it and they
really were excited to teach.
It was like a chance for them
to share what they know with
somebody who really wanted
to learn it.
All the chefs who said no, I'm
glad that they're not in the
book, because if they had a
hesitation to do the book then
I wouldn't want to have
them in the book.
So for the most part the
chefs that did the book
were eager to do it.
There are a couple of chefs--
Naomi Pomeroy at Beast in
Portland was really funny.
You'll see in her chapter,
there's a recipe for her
lentils, which I called
Lentilpalooza because there's
so much in it.
And so she was kind of
a little bit guarded.
So shed be making these lentils
and I would say, what
did you just put in there?
She was like, sun dried
tomatoes, and I'd be writing
down sun dried tomatoes.
And then she would add
three other things.
I was like, what was that?
And every time I turned
my back she would
be adding more things.
So it was a little bit like I
had to drag some things out of
certain chefs.
But overall they were
eager to share.
It was really great.
Thanks for your question.
So the question is how do you
shop at farmer's markets and
not get overwhelmed?
I still get overwhelmed,
it's true.
I think the key is
to go on a day--
my routine, mostly I'm living in
LA these days, is to go on
Monday to the farmer's market.
Monday is important that it's
Monday-- it's not Thursday,
it's not Saturday, it's Monday,
which means that I'm
buying stuff for the week.
Sunday and Monday--
it changes how you shop.
Because I think when I was going
on Friday or going if I
went on Saturday, it's like I'm
just shopping for a meal,
so I need to just buy something
for a meal.
What am I going to make?
I don't even know.
I'm so overwhelmed.
Whereas you go on a Monday, you
just grab things and you
don't even have to think about
what you're going to make.
You just have to give yourself
a license to buy stuff,
because I think that's
the key.
For me, I wouldn't give myself
permission to spend money on
those heirloom tomatoes because
I wasn't sure how I
was going to use them.
But when I changed my attitude
about it and I was like, no,
I'm just going to buy them, they
look beautiful, I'm going
to bring them home and I
will figure something
out when I get home.
And I think that's the key.
So you just buy--
a good strategy for me is that
I'll take a $20 bill out of my
wallet, I'll put in my pocket,
and that's what I'm spending
today at the farmer's market.
I'm going to spend $20, and I'll
just walk around and I'll
just buy things.
I take the change, put
it in my pocket, and
just buy, buy, buy.
Sometimes I just buy fruit.
I don't just buy fruit, but
I'll buy fruit to snack on
just so I have that
in the house.
So that's something to buy at
the farmer's market that will
always taste better
than something
at the grocery store.
And then other times, though,
I'll try to make myself buy
something I don't know what
it is or how to use
it, and I'll learn.
Like, garlic scapes are
a good example.
Garlic scapes are these crazy
looking things that grow on
top of garlic.
And so I bought those once.
I had no idea what they were.
I brought them home and
I looked up a recipe.
There's actually one in the book
for garlic scape pesto,
where you just blend it up with
olive oil and some nuts
and you can make a delicious
pasta sauce.
So, $20 in your pocket, give
yourself license to just buy
anything and everything.
Bring it home, put it on
display, and then make
yourself cook from that during
the week and use the internet.
Does that answer
your question?
OK, good.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you think you
can share on seafood and
barbecuing?
ADAM ROBERTS: A specific,
I mean--?
MALE SPEAKER: Any anecdotes,
stories of chefs--
kind of that kind
of combination.
Those are the things I'm
very interested in.
ADAM ROBERTS: Seafood is
interesting, because I didn't
cook a lot of seafood before I
wrote this book, because I
found it difficult-- because
I think seafood, more than
anything else, matters to
get it really fresh.
And so I would go to the grocery
store near where I
lived, and it would always
be wrapped in plastic.
I didn't have the energy to go
drive to the really nice fish
place all the time.
But one of chefs in the book
is Jonathan Waxman, who's a
chef at Barbuto in
New York, and he
was on Top Chef masters.
And they called him Obi-Wan,
because he's
sort of a Zen master.
When I was cooking with him, he
had a fishermen that came
in with this giant swordfish.
It looked like that, like a
wheel Parmesan cheese, but it
was a swordfish.
What was really fascinating
was he
improvised this fish stew--
it's in the front
of the book--
where he sliced big fillet
off the fish,
he cut it into cubes.
Actually, he had me do all this,
because that was what
was great about him, is he's a
great teacher, so he had me do
all the cutting, all
the cooking.
And so into a pot, we cook some
garlic and some fennel
and some onions, then we added
the fish and we added in some
mussels and clams and some white
wine, put the lid on.
And he made it seem so casual,
as if it was just the easiest
thing in the world.
The key to it, the key step--
this might be useful-- is just
to just cook it just enough.
Whenever I made seafood before,
I tended to overcook
the seafood, and overcooked
seafood is terrible.
So the key is just to cook it
just enough that it's just
cooked and you take it out.
So I think with fish especially,
what I sort of
learned is it goes from
translucent to opaque.
So you look at the color and if
you could see through it,
it's not done--
so using the color.
So he basically-- we poured that
out into a bowl, and it
was the most beautiful,
fragrant,
delicious, seafood stew.
And it was really all about
having that wonderful fresh
fish and using it in a really
simple way and cooking it just
the right amount to make
something delicious.
So maybe that's helpful
to you, I don't know.
But really, getting the best
fish you can get and cooking
it just enough is sort
of the best advice I
can give about seafood.
To me, the thing that makes
the book great or what I'm
proudest of about the book is
really trying to capture these
people's lives, these chefs'
lives, who they are, and how
that ties into the food
that they taught me.
And to me the most moving or
probably the most emotional
was Gina DePalma, who's the
pastry chef at Babbo in New
York, which is Mario Batale's
restaurant.
And when I cooked with her, she
was recovering from stage
four ovarian cancer.
And she was in remission,
and she was
going through all that.
And so her mother had been
making her this lentil soup to
feed her during her recovery,
and that was the soup that she
ate as got better from cancer.
And so basically that was the
dish that she taught me how to
make when I was in
her kitchen.
And even though it's a lentil
soup, whenever people ask me
what my favorite recipe in the
book is and I say lentil soup,
they kind of give me a look--
like, lentil soup?
But to me--
first of all, it's a
delicious recipe.
It has garlic oil that you
drizzle on at the end and it
has sausage and it has
kale, it has lots of
great stuff in it.
But much more importantly,
was the emotional--
how meaningful this
recipe was to her.
It made it very meaningful
for me.
So it wasn't the pyrotechnics of
a handful of flames, it was
more this really meaningful
recipe that
somebody shared with me.
And the fact that she opened up
her life and story to me--
that's the dedication at the
front of the book, is to all
the chefs who let m me into
their kitchens and let me into
their lives, because that's
what they did.
They really opened their doors
and I got to meet them and
meet their families and really
hear their stories.
That's probably how I'd
answer that question.
MALE SPEAKER: One of the big
differences I've seen between
a lot of restaurant cookbooks
and cookbooks that are more
meant for home cooks is a lot
of the restaurants will make
up large batches of individual
components that are finished
in some way and then
mix and match them.
Have you find any good ways of
adapting that for home use, or
have you tried to go towards
things that don't have as many
ingredients?
ADAM ROBERTS: Yeah, I'm
more of a one pot guy.
Like when I have people over for
dinner, I love to make a
braised dish, where you can
cook, like, short ribs or some
kind of fatty meat for a long
time so it breaks down.
And you just have that pot
simmering on the stove when
people show up and you can
just spoon it out.
Because that other kind of
cooking, which is very
restaurant driven-- and I
think there are a lot of
people at home who like the
challenge of making that kind
of food, which is why books
like Eleven Madison Park
Cookbook or Alinea cookbook or
the El Bulli cookbook, all
those books do well, because I
think there are fanatics who
will make all crazy
components.
So one of the chefs in the book
is Curtis Duffy, who is a
Michelin starred chef.
He had restaurant called Avenues
in Chicago and now
he's opening up a different
restaurant called Grace.
So when I came to cook with him,
he sort of got nervous,
because he's like, Adam, I have
to tell you, these dishes
that I make at this restaurant,
you're never going
to be able to adapt them
for the home cook.
I was like, what are
you talking about?
I can adapt anything.
He was like, this
is my corn soup.
And this corn soup has a dome
made with liquid nitrogen
that's made with coconut milk
and burnt corn husk oil that
you dip on the back of a ladle
and dip into liquid nitrogen
and you put the dome on top of
the corn soup and then you
shatter the dome
into the soup.
You're never going to
be able to do that.
And I was like, how do
you make the soup?
He's like, the soup is corn that
you blend up and then you
strain it and then you cook it
and you blend it with sugar
and olive oil.
I was like, teach me that.
So he taught me just how to make
the corn soup, and it's
absolutely the best corn
soup I've ever had
in my entire life.
So in the book when you
see the corn soup,
it's just corn soup.
But it's a great corn soup, and
it's a corn soup that you
can make for your family, you
can make for a dinner party,
and it doesn't ask you to buy
liquid nitrogen, it doesn't
ask you to make burnt
corn husk oil.
And so those are things that
I'm not interested in.
The book is sort of
my point of view--
taking these recipes and
filtering them through my
point of view.
And my point of view is to
cook more crowd pleasing,
comforting sort of realistic
dishes, not the dishes that
have 30 components on them.
So that's a great question.
And yeah, it's not my cup of tea
to do that, but I really
admire those who do.
Thanks.
Well, thank you guys so much
for having me here today.
I really enjoyed
talking to you.
And I'll be signing the book
afterward, so go buy a copy
and thanks again.